-- GOOD AFTERNOON -- WELCOME
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE -- ON
THE APRIL TWENTY SECOND --
THIS RULES TO ENSURE BY COLD
ORDER VICE AND AUDIO AND VIDEO
ACCORDING TO THESE PROCEEDINGS
BE MADE AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
AHMED SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL PULLING HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO YEAH FLORA GRAYSON
HERE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS REVERSE
SIR WICKS WE HAVE A MONTH
OVERHEAD AND WELCOME BACK ALL
WE HAVE A CORE WE HAVE CONSENT
AGENDA -- AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE CONSENT AGENDA IS MOTION
TO RESPECTFULLY OBJECT TO THE
URGENCY REQUEST OF AB SIXTY
ONE I DO NOT AGREE THAT THE
BILL REQUIRES TAKEN HE IN
FACT THIS TIME THERE FOR THE
CLOSEST REQUESTED US WE BOTH
ON A SEPARATE CASE THAT WILL
BE THE ORDER THEN -- IS OUR
MOTION ON THE REMAINDER OF THE
BECAUSE CALENDAR -- MOVERS TO
REVERSE -- CERTAIN THE MEASURE
ALMOST OKAY -- MATT SECTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
I FOR RIO AYE FLORA I AGREE
SENATE RACE AND I KAMLAGER-DOVE
HI KAMLAGER-DOVE OF IRON MAN
TRYING MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS
MATHIS ARTWORK SO FAR RAMOS
RAMOS I RIVERSIDE RIVERSIDE
WORKS WITH SORRY LEVINE HI
LEVINE AYE -- VERY GOOD AND WE
HAVE TO HAVE A MOTION ON ITEM
HERE'S A REQUEST FOR A V.
SIX AND SALAS MOVE ON THIS
CARILLO -- SECONDED --
THIS CALL THE ROLL
HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO HI CARILLO OURS FLORA
LARA NOW GRAYSON BY RACE AND I
KAMLAGER-DOVE RIGHT NOW MONEY
BUYING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MATHIS NO QUIRK
SILVA FROM MOST FROM MOST AYE
REAVIS REVERSE IRAQ'S WORKS
ARE LIVING LIVING IN ISOLATION
PROCESS OCEAN PASSED -- AND
NEXT RULES BECAUSE IT TURNED